Having stopped The Reach Invasion and Broken
the Light in half, the team will now operate
out of the watchtower.
Side by side with The League.
Not because Mount Justice was destroyed, but
because you earned it.
And So we leave you to it.
This team has had successes, but much remains
to be done.
Superboy, Miss Martian, Beast Boy, you're
Alpha.
Ba'Arzoum has called from Mars, he needs help.
Tigress, Kid Flash, Bumblebee, Guardian, you're
Beta.
Lexcorp is bringing out the Reach Soft Drink
under a new name.
We need proof.
Business as usual.
The rest of you are Gamma, and will investigate
Batgirl's lead on Vandal Savage's next move.
Business as usual.
Hey Youtubers happy early holiday's new gift
young justice season three is this can be
a breakdown of what the hell's going on and
why this is so awesome season three is happening.
This is not a joke.
This is not a drill.
This is totally real Warner Bros. announce
Warner Bros. animation that they're working
on a new season.
They did not announce when it's coming out
with the cast is going to be what changes
they're going to be from the original series
but I think they're going to try and keep
everything in continuity as much as possible,
it's been about 3 1/2 years since the season
two finale aired there were 20 episodes in
season two, so we can guess they might do
between 13 and 20 episodes or whatever new
season they're doing.
They did a really big time jump between season
one in season two they might just choose to
do the exact same thing for season three.
But they basically ended the second season
like if you haven't watched it a long time
with a big blue beetle arc where like the
villains of the blue beetle comics like this
insectoid race tries to invade the earth they're
able to stop them.
So what they might do pure because that threat
was taken care of at the end of that series
is they might choose to do a rebirth reef
formation of the team.
Show them getting the band back together or
they could just pick up like they never lost
a step, it's really easy to do that with animation
because the actors don't visibly age they
can just draw the characters, however old
they want to the funny thing about the season
to timeline is that it actually takes place
during 2016.
So hilariously they could actually pick up
on the next day if they wanted to like 20
17th whenever the series ends up dropping
with.
The thing is is that animation takes a lot
longer to produce.
So I would expect in late 2017 mid 2018 like
a summer release just depends on when they
start working on it and how much money they
throw into it using the faster you try to
get stuff out the bigger the animation team
has to be the cause starts polluting so I'm
just expecting this late 2017.
Like maybe a trailer sometime next year and
then at 2018 release at the latest.
I don't think it will be later than that but
usually the easiest thing for them to get
out is the actual scripts the ideas for the
stories.
So that's what you'll probably hear about
it at comic con next year if they don't drop
the trailer which they probably will some
of the probably do now is that the producers
will slowly start teasing stuff out until
they make an actual revealed like this is
what the team is going to be here.
Some promo art and then we'll get some actual
footage so let me know where you want them
to pick up with episode one of season three
and keep in mind that they kept this on earth.
16.
So it was taking place on a different earth
from the main DC comics so they could do Damien
Wayne stuff but all the movie animation stuff
that's been happening recently like they did
the teen Titans movie about the origin of
Raven was tried on by their explanation young
justice takes place in a separate universe
so they could mix that if they want they could
totally wreck on that but anything that showed
up during season one season twos fair game
for much any DC character, it's a lot easier
for them to use really big characters for
the animated series than it is for the live-action
TV shows.
But this does draw a little bit of water on
the idea of a live-action young justice TV
show because they're doing the animated series
so the pry will do those the same time, I
know they have a lot of the young justice
characters in the live-action flash arrow
Supergirl TV shows or they might choose to
do BQ because the teen Titans TV show the
TNT was trying to develop kind of fell through
that that went away.
They're not making that anymore they could
pick that up on the CW for whenever arrow
goes off the air, but I'm not expecting that
to happen for at least another two years.
So Merry Christmas, happy holidays.
You know whatever December holiday it is that
you guys celebrate this is like your first
big present let me know if the gonna do animated
young justice.
What do you want them to do when arrow goes
off the air on the CW do you want them to
do live-action teen Titans or do you want
them to actually try for live-action young
justice.
Because they done this.
And even though it's a long ways off before
going to get any footage or trailer or anything
like that.
I'm totally happy to do young justice bonus
videos.
So if you do want any specific things just
let me know in the comments be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
This reminds me of when legend of Cora went
off the air like a beautifully animated series
that was written really well but was really
expensive and didn't make a lot of money for
Nickelodeon that's Nickelodeon show Warner
Bros. did young justice.
Obviously, but the reason they canceled young
justice is because it wasn't selling any toys
and that's how they monetize the cartoons
at that time.
Typically, TV shows, earn their money based
on the advertising they self select when you
see a commercial during a TV show the TV show
makes money based on that.
So the more people watched the higher the
advertising rates the more money the TV show
makes the longer they keep it on the air.
A lot of cable animated series are different
they don't monetize them like prime time shows
so young.
Justice was built on the strength of its toy
sales.
They didn't sell, so they canceled the TV
show which is a huge bummer because it was
really popular a lot of people watched it
but because that wasn't their benchmark for
success.
They still cancel that but they probably found
a smarter way to earn money from it so that's
why they bring it back and because everybody
wants it to get I it's gonna be awesome just
because this happened all post my walking
dead video next to be doing walking dead trailer
video so that we the post later tonight or
early tomorrow morning we just wait for that
to post you can click here for all my Dr.
strange Easter eggs and click here for the
trailer for the next episode of the flash
Thank You so much for watching everybody let's
High Five and I'll see you tonight!